There are probably a few people covered here at biographics who are more
defensive than Ned Kelly. Australia's most famous outlaw and Bush ranger.
He is primarily remembered for his final showdown with the police where Ned and
his men wore homemade armor to some people. He, a folk hero,
a working class revolutionary who took a stand against British colonial
authority to others.
He's simply a cold blooded villain who has been undeservedly mythologized and
morphed into a sort of Robin hood of Australia will that you hear his story and
form your own opinion, but there is one thing for certain, for better or worse.
Ned Kelly has become one of Australia's greatest cultural life.
Ned Kelly was born in Beaver Ridge Victoria,
which back then was still a colony of the British crown.
His date of birth is unknown, but it's generally believed to be either December,
1854 or June, 1855. His father was John Kelly, also known as reds,
an Irish criminal,
who was transported to Australia in his early twenties for stealing pigs.
He served his time on van Diemen's land,
better known today as Tasmania and afterwards,
like many other convicts see chose to remain in Australia and make a new life
for himself. Instead of returning home, read, worked various odd jobs,
which included being a farm hands for the Quinn family group of Irish immigrants
who settled in Melbourne.
Then he met 18 year old Ellen Quinn and the two married in 1850.
This was around the time that Australia became grips with gold fever and many
men tried their luck prospecting. John Kelly was among them.
And while he didn't exactly strike it rich,
he made enough for him in Netherlands to buy a farm of their own in a developing
town called Beaver Ridge that ate children together with Ned being the oldest
son he was named after John's closest brother Edward,
and according to family tradition,
he came into the world with the Eureka rebellion,
a conflict between prospectors and colonial forces, which occurred in late 1854,
quite fittingly,
Ned Kelly would go on to develop an aversion to authority all his life,
particularly to the police.
The family hoped his beverage grew so would their fortunes,
but this didn't happen.
The main road to Beaver Ridge was very treacherous and it's alternative routes
that bypass the town completely became the standard roads travel.
The family farm did not flourish and the Kellys lost money.
And John started drinking.
Things got so bad that eventually they had to sell the farm and move to another
town called Avondale during the mid 1860s.
That Ned Kelly is still remembered by many as a hero even today,
particularly for an incident when he was just 10 years old and he saved the life
of a younger boy who was drowning for this.
He was rewarded with a green sash made out of fine silk.
There came one of Ned's most treasured possessions,
and even wore it under his clothes during his final confrontation with the
police. After first arriving in Australia and serving his time.
John Kelly tried hard to walk the straight and narrow and avoid any more legal
troubles, but temptation the best of him in 1865,
when his family was struggling for food, a calf wandered onto his lands,
even though it was branded as belonging to one, Phillip Morgan drunk,
killed and butchered it from meat.
He was caught and charged with cattle stealing and had to do six months of hard
labor. The work plus the drinking took the toll on John's health.
He died in December, 1866, leaving the twelve-year-old.
Ned is the new man of the family.
[Inaudible].
A few years later, the Kelly family had to move again.
This time do a stretch of uncultivated farmland outside the town of Gretta.
There, they reunited with a lot of relatives as Ellen's parents and sisters,
along with their own families had relocated to the area wherever they went.
The Quinn's developed a reputation for not being the most law abiding people in
the world and often work used of cattle and horse stealing that began spending a
lot of time with his uncles who undoubtedly influenced his developing behavior.
But the defining moment came in 1869.
When the 14 year old Kelly met Harry power, power real name,
Henry Johnson was a well-known Bush ranger.
Originally Bush Rangers were escaped. Convict convicts,
use the Australian wilderness as a hideout.
It later came to refer to all criminals who hid in the Bush.
They were undoubtedly criminals who committed robberies and even murders,
but they still had their fair share of sympathizes, Ned Kelly,
or to quite a few others became regarded as folk heroes who stood up civil
authority similar to the Outlaws of the American West Harry power was one such
example. The Kellys were as simplifies as nadis in particular,
took an instant liking not only to power, but to the lifestyle itself.
He became the Bush Rangers protege,
helping him steal horses and commit robberies.
Unsurprisingly Ned's first brush with the law occurred at this time when he
stood accused of assaulting and robbing a Chinese merchants,
Ned was arrested when he was 15,
but his sister and two family friends testified that it was in fact,
the merchants who instigated the assaults as the latter had no witnesses on his
side. Police had no choice, but to let Ned Kelly go, he was later again,
arrested as an accomplice in several robberies,
committed by power that none of the victims could positively identify him.
That's association with Harry power. It ended in June,
1870 when the latter was caught and arrested. However,
his influence on his young protege was too much to overcome.
And Ned Kelly had already built a reputation as a local hoodlum and newspaper
called the Benalla Ensign wrote about their relationship saying this.
The effect of power's example has already been to draw one young fellow into the
open vortex of crime. And unless his career is speedily cut short,
young Kennedy will blossom into a declared enemy of society.
Pretty much what happens from that point on Ned.
Kelly always stayed on the wrong side of the law.
Just a few months after power's arrest,
Ned was taken into custody for assaulting a Hawker named Jeremiah McCormack.
This time he was found guilty and sentenced to six months of hard labor.
He was really sturdy,
only enjoyed a few weeks of freedom before being incarcerated.
One small of a horse theft.
This challenge was later downgraded to falling asleep, receiving a horse,
but Kelly still got three years in prison when he was released.
Kelly went back to stealing livestock this time accompanied by his younger
brother, Dan Kelly, a bit later,
they would go on to form the Kelly gang whose other main members included Steve
Hart and John Byrne and other defining moments in the life of Ned Kelly took
place on April the 15th, 1878, known as the Fitzpatrick incidents.
It is sometimes seen as the catalyst that irrevocably put Ned and his brother on
the path of no return as they became wanted fugitives. Unfortunately,
we cannot say with certainty what happened because we have two different
versions of events that's of Constable Alexander Fitzpatrick and that's if the
County family and neither one is a particularly reliable source Fitzpatrick
traveled on that date to the Kelly household to take down into custody as there
was an arrest warrant out on him for horse theft, according to the Constable,
the arrived at the house where he found Dan Kelly, his mother Ellen,
and two associates named William Williamson and bill skillion.
He agreed to allow Dan to finish dinner before taking him in.
But while he was waiting, Neta appeared and restrained him.
The Bush ranger shot Fitzpatrick in the arm while Ellen knocked him unconscious
with a far shovel, they later let him go.
After retrieving the bullet from his hand using a knife,
the Kelly version was a bit different.
They said Fitzpatrick came to the house drunk and without a warrant Ned wasn't
there at the time. It's the Constable native passages sister, Kate Kelly.
At that point,
Dan and Fitzpatrick stones had fighting Constable pulled out his revolver,
right at that moment,
Ned entered the home and helped his brother overpower the police officer who
injured his arm in the scuffle. It was an old established conclusively.
The Fitzpatrick's injury came from a gum shot.
The doctor who inspected him also noted that the Constable smelled of alcohol,
although Fitzpatrick claims that he stopped for a drink on the way back to
steady his nerves. It wasn't the most trustworthy witness,
but the police accepted as evidence anyway, and arrest warrants were issued.
Ned and Dan Kelly went on the run while Ellen Williamson and skillion which
charged and convicted of being accessories to attempted murder public reaction
of the time. It was very negative to the trial,
particularly the sentencing of the elderly Ellen Kelly to hard labor.
Even the Victoria police.
Weren't happy with Fitzpatrick's actions as the commissioner decried them as
generally bad and discreditable to the force. However,
they did generate plenty of sympathy for the Kelly brothers.
In hindsight.
And Dan with joins by Joe Byrne and Steve Hortons,
the group hopes to raise enough money to appeal, Alan Kelly's sentence.
Like we said, a lot of locals were on their side.
So they were tipped off in late October when the police discovered their
whereabouts and dispatched an armed party to their location, to take them down.
The police group consisted of Forman, Sergeant Kennedy and constables,
Lonergan McEntire and Scanlon on October the 25th, 1878.
They arrived in the camp that stringy bark Creek. However,
none of them were experienced bushmen like Ned Kelly,
knowing that were out there somewhere.
He found their horse tracks and followed them to their camp where Kelly and his
gang took them by surprise. What happened next is again,
a controversial and uncertain matter as accounts differ.
And some argue that the story has been embellished over the decades to portray
Kennedy in a more positive manner.
Basically it all hinges on whether or not the Kelly gang gunned down the
officers in cold blood.
When they mentioned the camp only to policemen with that,
Lonigan the Macintosh Macintosh was quickly disarmed and surrendered peacefully
while Lonigan was shot and killed by net Kelly. Allegedly, he tried to run,
but he hadn't had bad blood.
So it's also possible that Kelly intended to kill him.
Regardless when Scanlan and Kennedy returns to the camp,
they found Macintosh sitting on a log ins, the Kelly gang waiting an ambush,
a shootout ensued where Scanlon was shot dead and Kennedy was mortally injured,
crawling a few hundred feet before dying.
During the chaos Macintosh managed to jump on a horse and make a run for it.
He reached civilization and informed everyone that the Kelly gang had just
murdered three police officers, whether or not the officers would have lived.
If they surrendered, we cannot say.
But from that point on the Kelly gang were officially declared Outlaws by the
governor of Victoria under the reasonably passed felons apprehension act.
They basically had no more rights. They could be shot on site,
even if they were captured.
Alive.
The Kelly gang were active for approximately two years,
but they spent most of that time in hiding in the Australian Bush,
relying on friendlies to provide them with food and lodging.
The police knew this since they could not capture the Kelly gang.
They decided to crack down hard on their sympathizers.
Fortunately for the authorities,
the AFA mention felons apprehension act also allowed them to punish those who
offered any aid shelter or sustenance Outlaws.
So they were pretty much free to in prison.
Anyone they felt were on the side of Ned Kelly in one particularly egregious
example in January, 1879,
one captain Standish rounds it up 23 men who were believed to be either friends
or sympathizers of the Outlaws and in prison them for months without charge.
If anything is such abuse as a power only serve to portray Ned Kelly in a more
positive light as more and more people began to see him as a man fighting
against injustice.
The Bush ranger helps enhance this reputation by rising the so-called Gerald
Arie letter, a 56 page 8,300 word bene Festo,
where he decried the abuses of the police,
whom he described as a parcel of big ugly, fast neck, wombat headed big bellied,
magpies and legs,
narrow hips to explore footed sons of Irish bailiffs or English landlords,
which is better known as the offices of justice or Victorian police SU
some goal honest gentlemen in the lesser Kelly argued that he was forced into
becoming an outlaw by circumstances outside of his control. He still blamed.
Constable Fitzpatrick is the one who started all of this and called for justice.
Not only for him,
but for all the poor families of Australia who were subjugated by the terrorism
of the English yoke. During that time on the run,
the Kelly gang did have moments when they behave more like traditional Outlaws
is they robbed two banks.
The first one in the town of Euro took on December the 10th, 1878,
shortly after the shootout at stringy bark Creek,
the gang needed money and supplies to go into hiding. First,
they held up the nearby train station at faithful's creeks so they could rest
the horses dress up and respectable clothing and Telegraph lines.
Everyone who came to investigate was taken hostage and placed inside a store in
Bern,
stayed behind with the hostages while the other three went to Euroa bank and
cleaned it out. They then took the bank manager, Robert Scott,
and his family back to the story. So they couldn't raise the alarm.
And then they rode away leaving everyone's safe and uninjured.
There are additional details to this story,
such as the gang giving the hostages,
they horse trick riding show before leaving or Scott being so friendly with his
robbers, that they drank a whiskey together off to the empty to safe.
But it is hard to tell at this point of such things actually happens or they are
just more examples of colorful events added to boost the legend of Ned Kelly.
The second bank robbery occurred a few months later on February, the 10th, 1879,
and Gerald airy. The plan was similar.
Although this one was more ambitious in its execution.
The night before the gang descended upon the local police barracks,
where they took the only two offices inside as hostages, the next day,
they dressed up in police uniforms and managed to Rob the bank without any
violence.
They also bounce a of mortgage documents and took their horses to the local
blacksmith to get reissued posing the work on the police tab.
This is also when Kelly left behind his famous Gerald Arie letter,
although it wouldn't be published in its entirety until 1930.
[Inaudible].
Following the two robberies authorities stepped up their efforts to hunt down
the Kelly gang, even more with contributions from banks.
They increased the reward for their capture.
It's a 2000 pounds per head for a total of about 8,000 pounds,
which is about 1.5 million Australian dollars in modern currency.
They also brought in an easy police unit from Queensland,
which contained Aboriginal troopers who were more adept at tracking people in
the Bush. Ultimately they were able to find the Outlaws,
but it has been speculated that their efforts were hampered at every turn,
by the Victoria police who didn't want it to get upstaged by the Queenslanders.
They were already deeply unpopular with the people of Victoria.
Those who sympathized with Ned Kelly considered them to be corrupt and abusive.
Those who didn't still regarded them as incompetent for being unable to capture
the gang.
The last thing they needed was for the Queensland is to do that job for them.
In the end, it was the money that gave them the advantage.
The Kelly gang may have been popular with the people,
but it was inevitable that someone would ultimately choose funds over
friendship, that someone was Aaron sharer.
So friends of the gang members who was particularly close to Joe Burton,
he became an informant for the police.
Although some believed he was actually trying to act as a double agent.
Even the authorities suspected this,
but they found a way of making him useful regardless of his true loyalties,
the police made sure that word spread around that share.
It was working with them.
They were hoping to entice the Kelly gang out of hiding,
using share it more as bait than as an informant. This actually worked.
The gang felt betrayed by sharers and burn in particular,
wanted him dead on June the sixth, 1880.
He and Dan Kelly traveled to wool shed Creek where Sharon lived.
There were four police officers inside the Sherrard home that night.
So the gang needed a way of separating that target from the group.
They kidnapped a neighbor and brought him to the front door of the Sheriff's
house while they learned hiding.
They made him call out for sharer to recognized his neighbor's voice and
answered the door without hesitation. At that point,
Bern popped down to the shadows and shot him through the hat.
This was the first part of that plan is the Kelly gang sets only enacting the
most ambitious and most violent ploy. Yes.
They knew that the police inside sheruts home would send word of what had
happened to Melbourne, who in turn would send reinforcements by special train.
The rail would pass through a city called Bonilla where undoubtedly more
officers would join the hums.
And then through a town called Glenn Rowen while Dan and Ben delts with
sheriffs, Ned and Steve Hart traveled to Glen Rowan.
Their intention was to run the train off the track, kill any survivors,
and then go onto Bonilla,
which left without a police force would have been easy pickings.
So their sentence,
nebs and tasks kidnapped to railway workers and forced them at gunpoint damage
the track over steep ravine afterwards, they went inside the town,
took the locals hostage and pack them inside the Glen road in waiting for the
train to arrive from Manila.
This was all building up to one bloody confrontation,
but the Kelly gang had one last memorable ACE up their sleeves.
One so unusual that the police didn't even believe it.
When they heard reports from the locals over the course of the previous months,
the gang members had constructed who made armor for themselves out of pieces of
metal plow moldboards they weighed almost a hundred pounds, each iconic look,
which was plastered over every newspaper in Australia. Undoubtedly,
it was instrumental in creating the legend of Ned.
Kelly is almost a day as a place of honor at the state library of Victoria.
Those of Dan and hotter on display at the Victoria police museum while burns is
in private hands. But back to the night in question,
the Kelly gang had over 60 hostages, Glen run it. They pass the time with music,
dancing games and drinking. Everybody was seemingly having a good time,
even perhaps too much of a good time.
As he became convinced that he was surrounded by sympathizes,
that let his guard down and allowed the local.
Schoolmaster a man named Thomas kernel to return home and go to sleep.
Kernel was not only a sympathizer,
but he had overheard the gangs plan of derating. The train. He went home,
grabbed a candle and a red handkerchief and went to the railway to find the spot
where the tracks had been damaged after locating it.
He managed to signal the engine driver in time,
then to stop the train derailing,
the entire police force was alive and well and headed for the Glen run in.
They surrounded the hotel and the shooting started.
The Kelly gang quickly saw that their planet fails,
but had no intention of surrendering. They put on their armor and fought back.
Most of the house just made it out safely.
The women and children were released at the beginning and most of the rest
managed to sneak out the back during the chaos, two bystanders,
both men were caught in the gunfire and died after sustaining a few minor
injuries. The Outlaws retreated further inside the hotel,
except for Ned Kelly who ran into the Bush intending to circle around and flank.
The police,
Joe Byrne was the first to die abilities in the thigh and severed his femoral
artery causing him to bleed out.
Then came the most spectacular moment of the shootouts.
Ned Kelly emerged out of the dark mist cloud in Alma and guns blazing the same
made the police think that they were fighting the devil himself.
And Dick took the minutes to finally understand what was happening.
Eventually they realized that Ned's legs were completely unprotected.
So they aimed for those.
Kelly took several shots before finally collapsing and surrendering.
He was captured alive,
but Dan Kelly and Steve hall was still shooting from inside the hotel.
By this point, all the hostages had been evacuated.
The police had an artillery cannon coming in from Melbourne and they intended to
blow the entire hotel to smithereens. However, this took too long.
So instead they burned it to the grounds later,
they found the charred bodies of Kelly and heart and side who apparently died of
suicide by poison. And so the Kelly gang came to a bloody fiery end,
only Ned Kelly lived following the Glen Ron siege, but unsurprisingly,
it was tried for his crimes, found guilty and sentenced to death.
He still had tons of supporters who campaign for a reprieve,
but that please went on heated. Ned Kelly was hanged on November the 11th,
1880 at the Melbourne jail.
According to some reports as last words were such as.
Life.
I already have. You found that video. Interesting. If you did,
please do hit that thumbs up button below. Don't forget to subscribe.
And thank you for watching.